qu'est la gâtine et la production et la
33 et puis ma vérité on a toujours
l'impression qu'ils à morgan freeman
même quand il n'est pas mon globe
[Applaudissements]
le monde excusez moi toute sa part dans
des zones jusqu'à ce que je sorte de
tournage
ouais j'ai pris mon vélo je suis arrivé
direct et j'ai fait partie des dates
excuse moi aussi rires non mais je sais
c'est demain toi on n'est pas bien trop
dit on est mardi
mardi j'ai pas léger pas de cachet pour
tout ce que tu as déjà je peux faire
quelque chose pour les fixes et j'ai
grillé un feu tout est inquiète pas
alors bon vent à demain issa ces sept
années 40 et le costume d ariane la
petite scène sans les mettre en tirer
est ce que vous entendez prévu la tue la
wii wheel et ben carrington île de la
tentation mais on dirait qu'on avait des
mecs c'est lille s'est dit le doigt de
dieu dit de la détonation sous son
regard des mois l'équipe de regarder
l'équipe franchement
arrivent en bateau on va jouer est un
poids la demande des soldats français
alors les l'autre côté français c'est le
shérif messieurs on est de l'autre côté
de france de saint-malachie fusion ça
alors on est on en train de le donner
coachella
s'il vous plaît monsieur je vous êtes un
vrai nom la magie est ce que vous pouvez
laisser un temps suivi la note us lgt 2
50 euros ils m'agacent dechy non à
lessines mettez vos mains attend les
téléspectateurs voient de quoi il s'agit
alemanno et j'attaque à vous dire il ya
donc des papiers ou les récupérer moi
franchement je ne serai pas non mais
sérieux c'est ce qu'il ya de pire c'est
vrai
allez-y mais quel est ce important et je
ne donnerai pas le cadeau je donnerai
des seychelles à l'aigreur la chanson
cession allait et venait avec moi
connaître
contre l'immense
touché à l'aîné
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je veux bien leur nom mais vous allez
jaloux des trente secondes et sera la
dernière
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je râle
allez les gars y allez on y va aller la
presse ap ap un ordinateur date et la
série a été un vrai talent excuse moi
caroline elle va te faire perdre par le
bris mais pour toi caroline je vais pas
m'emballer
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
valérie est ce que vous les mettez vos
mains mettez vos mains mais donnez-moi
vos mains donnez-moi dans l'archipel je
ne veux pas qu'ils me touche mais celle
des arêtes malaisie oui mais c'est pour
aller on y enlève ta main les manuels
mais c'est l'animal n'est pas la
question
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]